so getting into part two of our coverage
of the Marvel Zombies story what we're
told here is that at some point
alternate read have been contacted by an
alternate reality version of himself who
had intended to bring together the
brightest minds in the multiverse for an
unknown mission as a result ultimate
read had begun production of a portal
that could allow transport to this
alternate reality and in turn allow its
occupants to transport to the ultimate
universe using the teleporter for the
first time ultimate read lands in the
zombie universe amidst the ruins of the
Baxter building travelling through the
streets and finding the world virtually
devoid of all life Reid comes
face-to-face with the zombified versions
of himself and the rest of the Fantastic
Four because a situation proves to be
overwhelming and ultimate Reid is very
naive relative to his other self he
doesn't quite grasp the nature of the
situation and that he was lured here
because the zombies had simply run out
of food fleeing for his life becoming
face to face with the various other
zombies within the zombie universe the
group is much intrigued by Reid as they
are interested in consuming him for a
couple of reasons the first is that they
initially don't know he teleported there
from another dimension leading them to
believe that there may be a supply of
human still in existence on the planet
even after most were presumably
teleported away by dr. doom the second
reason is because he looks exactly like
Reid from the zombie universe albeit
younger which leaves the group to
realize that he is from an alternate
reality meaning the opportunity exists
for them to leave this universe in the
pursuit of new food however in the midst
of their curiosity and presumed
intention of consuming Reid the group is
suddenly set upon by a ton of vehicles
fleeing from the scene while some are
killed Reid is met by the arrival of
Magneto the last surviving super-powered
being on the face of the earth bringing
Reid to their hideout magneto
establishes that from the time the
century attacked the first hero to the
time that Reid has just now arrived only
three days have passed during which all
but 12 humans were consumed by the
zombies in addition to this one of the
survivors a girl named Kelly bridge
immediately takes up arms against Reid
because of the fact that all of the
super-powered beings - magneto are
infected and because individuals like
mystique use shape-shifting as a way to
infiltrate human groups and consume them
Kelly along with several of the other
survivors are weary of Reid's presence
as he explains Reid himself is from
another reality whereby the zombie
infection has not appeared while magneto
consider
to be a problem due to the fact that the
zombies have a way out of this reality
and into a new one at the same time the
possibility exists that they can escape
this universe and take refuge in another
one however before they can leave the
group is attacked by Thor and the
Avengers who track them using Wolverines
ability to pick up sense using his
powers over magnetism magneto throws a
train at the group allowing himself the
humans and read an opportunity to escape
and so rather than finding refuge once
they get outside the group is met with a
host of zombified heroes and villains
including electra beast
storm and black bolt of the Inhumans and
so in the midst of attacking the group
the various zombies suddenly begin
writhing in agony with Hank Pym
declaring that he's been blinded along
with all of the other zombies making
their presence known it's revealed that
Susan storm Ben Grimm and Johnny had
used the portal from the Ultimate
Universe
to arrive in this reality with Susan
having used her power to create force
fields in the zombies eyes causing them
to go blind using this opportunity to
escape the remaining four or five humans
who survived the attack as well as a
fantastic four prepare to leave by way
of the teleporter and while magneto is
offered the opportunity to leave as well
he decides to stay due to the fact that
someone needs to remain behind to
destroy the teleporter and ensure that
the zombies are unable to rebuild it and
make their way back through now at this
point the story picks up with the actual
five-part Marvel Zombies event with
magneto staying behind following the
departure of the ultimate Fantastic Four
we pick up with him attempting to escape
the zombie horde leading them on a merry
chase along the way the Acolytes magneto
had left on asteroid M at the start of
the outbreak are able to re-establish
contact stating that several of them had
died when various super-powered
individuals had attempted to invade and
forming the group that his intention is
to make his way back to asteroid M
because the use of his powers to destroy
the portal was so exhausting and the
constant escape from the zombies hasn't
given him the chance to recover magneto
is unable to escape earth by travelling
directly through space continuing to
avert the zombies Magneto's location is
discovered by Hawkeye who signals the
rest of the group
taking refuge in a construction site
Marvel provides us with a literal last
man standing with magneto using his
powers to fend off the combined forces
of the zombies
while handling his own 4-time in a
moment of arrogance when he challenges
the zombies and declares that they were
foolish were timid to kill him and an
area surrounded by steel and concrete
wast transforms into her full form and
attacks magneto from behind succumbing
to the infection magneto is then
consumed by the zombies which officially
means that all of the living beings on
the planet Earth are completely gone
from here the story jumps forward to the
arrival of the Silver Surfer heralding
the coming of Galactus because he was
quite literally travelling to the world
at SuperSpeed
the zombies don't initially spot him but
after several glimpses of him travelling
around the world the group begins to
spread out furthermore because the human
population was believed to have been
completely wiped out it's revealed that
Hank Pym has actually been harvesting
the limbs of Black Panther as a way to
keep his hunger at bay while
simultaneously attending to find a cure
for the plague
however while in the midst of feasting
Hank Pym is suddenly set upon by wasp
who had been following him becoming fed
up with her nonsense rather than
slapping her across the face instead
Hank Pym simply bites her head off
picking back up with the rest of the
group the Silver Surfer makes his
appearance known by declaring that the
planet will soon be met with the arrival
of Galactus the Devourer of worlds but
instead of panicking and running for the
hills
the zombies immediately attack the
Silver Surfer where we would normally
believe that the Silver Surfer could
easily repel the zombies due to his
possession of the power cosmic and avast
abilities that it provides because of
the sheer number of zombies attacking
the surfer he's completely overwhelmed
and as a result the zombies consume him
which in turn provides all of them with
an equal share of the power cosmic at
the same time this is happening
Black Panther had come to and seize the
opportunity to patch himself up and make
an escape along with the severed head of
wasp now where the Marvel Zombies story
is largely action with little room for
interpretation the conversation between
wash and Black Panther is actually one
of the most important parts of this
story the reason why is because this
sets the stage for a way to end the
zombie plague without actually curing
the zombies as she explains the desire
for the consumption of flesh is
all-consuming and her body physically
aches because of her need for flesh but
as Black Panther points out the fact
that she's disembodied indicates that
the pain that she experiences from a
lack of consuming flesh is largely
psychological however before the
conversation can continue any further
black panther is met by the arrival of
Fabian Cortez a mutant with the ability
to enhance the powers of other mutants
as well as the rest of the acolytes at
this point we transition to the arrival
of Galactus intending to consume the
planet in order to satisfy his hunger
after asking the zombies what had
happened to his Herald the Silver Surfer
ant-man simply responds that they ate
him and so using their newly acquired
power cosmic to attack Galactus and
attempt to consume him
the zombies are repelled with little
effort from Galactus himself now
retreating and taking time to form a
plan the story transitions to Black
Panther again following his discovery by
the acolytes with magneto missing the
presumed dead the acolytes arrived on
earth led by Fabian Cortez for the
purpose of investigating what it wasn't
it happy to magneto and why he never
reported in because black panther looks
worse for wear after being harvested for
his limbs and because those with
superpowers sustain themselves even
after being infected the acolytes
believe that he's a zombie with one of
the members attacking him
Black Panther defends himself by
throwing the severed head of Janet Van
Dyne at his assailant as well as doing
what he can to fight physically however
before the conflict gets too far Cortes
steps in and forces has been to stand
down now this is in stark contrast to
the Fabian Cortez of the normal Marvel
continuity and that de Fabian Black
Panther and the Acolytes represent
what's left of humanity because of this
if they are to survive they have to work
together instead of fighting and that
the demise that his fellow members met
with was a result of their own actions
with black panther simply fighting to
protect himself now transitioning back
to the zombies we learn the following
the retreat from Galactus ant-man and
several others had left for several days
in an effort to find a way to defeat
Goliath and consume him in addition what
Marvel does here is provide us with a
little insight into the zombies and
cells and how they function in this new
world according to spider-man when he's
asked by Luke Cage why he continues to
wear his mass as fight everything that's
going on
Peter replies that after eating his aunt
and Mary Jane he can't bear to look at
himself in the mirror now what this does
is set the early stage for the events
that we'll see in Marvel Zombies 2 which
will see a civil war among the various
characters but it also tells us that
despite everything that's happened
the zombification of Peter and the
others hasn't really destroyed who they
are instead
allows them to maintain the overall
identities while simultaneously driving
them to consume flesh and so with
Wolverine arriving and informing the to
that ant-man read and the others have
returned we learn that during the days
in which they were hiding out and in
order to satisfy their hunger for flesh
the group has quite literally been
digging into their own stomachs pulling
out the digested remains of the Silver
Surfer
and re eating them furthermore the
reason for Ant Man and the others
leaving was to gather vibranium from
Wakanda some unidentified materials from
Castle doom and the Baxter building as
well as several crystals from dr.
Strange's sanctum sanctorum what we
don't initially know what these were for
the reason for requiring these items
becomes apparent when the group
assembles them into a device that I
don't recognize and attacked Galactus
with it however because the actions of
Galactus assembling the world destroyer
device has drawn the attention of
multiple zombified heroes and villains a
battle breaks out between the group over
ant-man's team putting in the work to
defeat Galactus versus the heroes who
have arrived and laid claim to it
descending into a miniature civil war
what Marvel's doing here is basically
thinning out the herd as a way to scale
down on the focal characters of the
story as an example while Eddie Brock is
still in possession of the Venom
symbiote as he explains after being
infected by the zombie virus
the symbiote itself is dying and seems
to have been biologically incompatible
with Eddie following his infection where
Marvel leaves this a little ambiguous
the overall theme is that Eddie Brock
ends up dying after being attacked by
spider-man and so while the battle is
relatively short-lived in the end
ant-man states that consuming Galactus
is more important than fighting the
other zombies as a result the group uses
the power cosmic to kill the remainder
of the zombies and turn their attention
to consuming khalaqtu s' now at this
point this story jumps forward by five
years with Black Panther and the
acolytes returning Marvel drops a
massive bomb in the form of wasp as a
group travels throughout the planet we
learn that at some point during this
five-year period ant-man zombies had
left the earth after consuming Galactus
furthermore or is established that the
zombies don't die of starvation the
current form of wasps reveals that after
a certain amount of time has passed The
Hunger goes away which tells us that it
is entirely psychological now while this
bit of information with Black Panther
the Acolytes and wasp is short what the
story does is transition to an unnamed
race on the far side of the universe
with their various scientists reporting
to what appears to be the king we
learned that the race is expecting the
arrival of Galactus who has been cutting
a swath through the universe consuming
worlds left and right picking up with
his arrival we find the Galactus is
actually Ant Man zombie group who have
been feeding on the inhabitants of
countless planets across the cosmos
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it
now we'll catch you guys later peace